Wait,
she's
actually
trying
to to improve the coherency
of this manuscript by all.
I gave you the summary for the whole
thing last week,
week before,
and now I'm going to write a summary for
every chapter and hopefully that'll
provide a structure for the more
either elaborate or vague depending on
your perspective arguments that fall.
So,
so anyways,
what you have is the summary of the
preface,
which is very short and then a summary
of
the argument that I've been making
through that
it's reasonable to conceive of the world
in two ways.
Just trying to reduce that argument to
its essential aspect.
And then the last two pages contain
a description of the instinctive
response to novelty
and the manner in which that response
finds its representation and mythology.
And maybe by next week I'll have like
four more chapters,
summaries or something for you.
Then you look.
Okay,
so where are generally.
We've been discussing the possibility
that the dangers that are inherent to
group identity,
which is the tendency of group identity
to adopt that totalitarian stamps,
which is a consequence of its of any
groups propensity to try to maintain
that structure over time.
We're we're discussing the possibility
that that inevitable tendency of the
group might be heightened in its danger
by certain types of individuals.
Psychopathology,
and I was trying to make the argument
it's interesting,
you know,
this week in the Atlantic monthly,
there's a discussion of William James
and his,
his inquiry into religious
phenomenology,
which was apparently motivated in large
part by his use of nitric oxide,
but there's an also an argument in there
that elaborates upon shelly Taylor's
findings in social psychology that
positive illusions according to tailor
foster mental health.
Anyways.
That idea has now spread right out into
the mainstream press and the guy who
wrote the Atlantic monthly article and
just making the point that
the validity of a belief might be
determined by whether or not it makes
you happy.
She's a very,
very,
very dangerous perspective.
It's back to this,
back to this minority might these and I
brought that up is because of course
that's a point that's absolutely
contrary to the point that I've been
trained in making this class,
which is it's the individual tendency to
deceive themselves,
to deceive ourselves,
but the deceit oneself about the nature
of reality as it's defined personally.
That constitutes the basic form of
psychopathology attorneys with the
group,
which is a necessary but dangerous
structure into something that's
pathologically dangerous.
Now the argument,
basically I'll start,
we'll discuss that argument today a
little bit more detail,
but then I want to flip
to the last part of the course which is
a discussion of the process and that
hopefully will serve as an antithesis to
this individual pathology so you can
describe,
you know,
you can define thing something very well
by describing its opposite and that's
why we have anti heroes and literature
at least in part because they're good,
bad examples and you can infer the
opposite of something from the
description of that thing.
So it's perfectly reasonable to started
description of
identification with heroism.
I suppose by discussing its opposite.
You said,
I wrote a quote from him on page 211.
He said,
who alone has reason to lie himself out
of actuality and his answer to that was
he who suffers from it?
Well,
that's an interesting statement because
obviously it's not a description of an
individual person
or a way of drawing a distinction
between those who lie and those who
don't.
Really.
It's more a way of saying that since
it's obvious that everybody suffers from
actuality that everyone has sufficient
motivation to lie and what we're going
to try to get out a little bit today
again,
is
precisely what that motivation is
and then what the consequences,
the inevitable consequences of following
them additive and outpatient might be.
I made the point last week that it's
difficult to get a picture of the
process that serves as the adversarial
counterpart to the mythological hero
because
the reason that that process has been
described as a personality and mythology
because it consists of a number of a
number of things simultaneously and it's
difficult to discuss something that
consists of a number of things
simultaneously.
Because when we discuss anything,
you have to break it down into its
constituent elements and you risk over
simplifying the personality or reducing
it to something to one single thing that
it's not and the tendency ally is a
bunch of things at once that are all
interrelated and it would be a mistake
to try to reduce it to a single thing,
but I think at least in part
you can,
or one of the essential aspects of the
tendency to lie as rejection error.
Now there's a quote I'm going to read
you.
A quote from Milton behavior described
Satan's attitude and a
I have a little comment on that.
He says,
first which way I fly is hail myself,
am hill and in the lowest deep,
a lower,
deep,
still threatening to devour me,
opens wide to which the hell I suffer
seems to heaven.
The Devil Who's traditional
representation of evil refuses any
recognition of imperfection,
refuses to admit I was an error in my
action or in my representation,
accepts as a consequence of unbending
pride.
Eternal misery refuses Metanoia,
which is confession and reconciliation's
remains forever.
The spirit that refuses and rejects this
is a quote,
oh,
then at last,
relent is there no place left for
repentance now for pardon left,
not left by submission,
and that we're disdain for bids,
me and my dread of shame among the other
spirits beneath whom I seduced with
other promises and other violence than
to submit boasting.
I could subdue the omnipotent I me a
little.
Know how dearly I abide that boast so
vein under what torments inwardly I
grown well.
They adore me on the throat of hell with
dynamic sector,
high advanced,
the lower still,
I fall only supreme and misery.
Such joy,
ambition,
fines,
but say I could repent and could have
obtained by active grace,
my former state.
How soon should height recall?
High thoughts.
How soon unsay what fain submission.
Swore.
These would recant vows made in pain as
violent and void for never can.
True reconcilement girl,
where were wounds of deadly Hayden peers
so deep,
which would lead me to a worse relapse
and heavier fall.
So should I purchase deere short
intermission,
bought with double smart vis,
knows my punisher.
Therefore,
as far from granting heat as I from
begging piece,
all hope excluded us
such refusal,
the inability to say I was wrong,
I'm sorry,
I should change means the death of hope
and existence and how it should be.
This
right?
Rejection of fact means alienation from
meaning from truth and life without
meaning is suffering without recourse
where the have nothing but construction
in accordance with self definition.
So the idea I guess what we're trying to
do in a sense as to unpack what
rejection of error means.
You already know from looking at a
picture we put together of the
mythological portrait or portrayal of
reality that the,
that all new information is gathered as
a consequence of contact with a known.
I mean this is just a definition,
right?
You can't gather anything,
any new information unless you're
somewhere that you haven't been so to
speak.
You have to be in territory that's
unexplored to gather anything that's
normal.
Now,
the problem with that from a moral
perspective,
so to speak,
since we're dealing with behavior and
emotion,
is that the only way that you can get to
be somewhere that you don't know is by
admitting to the existence of anomalous
to the existence of anomaly and that's
tantamount to an admission that you were
incorrect.
The idea of
having your vision of yourself and where
you are and you're contracting with a
vision of where you want to be.
That's that's sort of your own
definition of what constitutes the world
and both of those polls are subject to
modification,
but you're the one who decides what the
polls are.
I mean you're.
You're setting up the rules of the game
and then if by your own definition,
your actions which are designed to bring
where you are to where you want to be
produced,
a contrary result,
that's anomalous.
That's an enormous piece of information.
By your own definition,
see you.
I stress that because the problem with
talking about something like error is
that you might think that implicit in
that discussion is the notion that
there's some that you have to make
recourse to an idea of absolute truth to
talk about error,
but you don't like.
This model is predicated on the notion
that you define the terms of the
argument for yourself,
which is to say you're the one who
decides where you are and also where
you're going.
I mean you pull in information from
outside to make those decisions of
course,
but still your game and if the actions
that you've constructed produce results
that you didn't intend,
that's what constitutes an anomaly.
So it isn't that you have to know
anything about absolute truth,
so to speak,
to determine when you are in fact an
error because you make the decisions.
Establishing a relationship or an aspect
of that information that you get back in
the context of that relationship when it
contradicts information is coming from
another source
rather than rather than it being some
sort of internal framework that you have
established.
Yes.
It's a conflict between the meaning
you're getting two different
relationships.
You have.
I would say that that's.
I would say that that's an equivalent,
that's an equivalent phenomenon because
it is one of the examples I'm using the
text made about abortion because you can
say,
well,
there's a lot of emotional intensity
surrounding the abortion debate because
it pits to cultural schemas against the
against one.
Another one says,
the right to life is paramount,
which is a perfectly no one position,
and the other position says no,
the right to freedom,
right to free choices.
Paramount.
Now,
under most circumstances,
most people in this society except both
of those,
uh,
moral presuppositions about abortion,
happens to be one situation,
assuming good will on both sides,
so to speak.
I'd have to be one situation where the
phenomena of the world presents us with
puts those two positions necessarily at
odds.
So then a third decision is necessary,
which is the decision to hierarchically
arranged to preceptive presuppositions.
So it can be the case that one
philosophical stance that's done in most
circumstances and another valid in most
circumstances and meet in a third place
and more in opposition.
So then you get a situation where there
there was an environmental phenomena
which would be the possibility of
unwanted possibility of abortion,
that the two moral systems,
which are modes of adaptation,
do not properly address.
And then what happens?
Well that's,
that's the eruption of an anomalous
occurrence into a cultural structure and
one of the things that happens when that
sort of thing happens is that you get a
war.
There is a war in this country between
those two positions.
It's just mostly still fought at the
level of words,
but not always.
So that's the.
That's a conflict of values.
And you said,
for example,
that the most difficult moral decisions
always come about when there's a
conflict of duty.
One valid principle says actually
pattern a.
another valid principle says action
pattern be the two action patterns
juxtapose,
juxtapose what was producing Iran
irreconcilable situation.
Then then the question is what do you
do?
What can you do?
Well,
that's part of what we're going to get
at when we,
when we get to the end of the argument
today,
it's impossible here and it's impossible
there.
What do you do?
That's the question.
Yeah.
I guess I was wondering whether those
two situations are analogous,
but the emphasis was slightly different.
Whether you've got to resolve it
internally or when did you've got to
resolve it in a sense of several hundred
connections with one of those.
Well,
that's an.
That's an option.
I would say one of the things we're
going to discuss today is consequences
of response patterns to anomalous
information and I would say well one
common way of dealing with the normal
occurrence that's so tight.
It's just a fortify the position that
you think is most appropriate and
exclude the rest.
Well,
it's that sort of solution writ large
and society.
I mean it has its advantages.
It's protected,
but it's also that sort of solution that
taken to an extreme causes.
What causes the walls to rise up around
communities.
One way of eliminating anomalous
information is to increase the
conformance and within the group and to
put more barriers up.
Just stop information from flowing in.
It's a good solution,
but it has its problems,
so anyone's is your idea that all the
anomaly is personal error is experienced
as personal level.
The asset.
I mean that's basically the idea.
Exactly.
Is that the unknown?
Actually,
because the unknown,
the way that we're construing it is a
phenomena that appears cloaked in
effect.
It's always necessarily making its
appearance on the scene of individual
consciousness.
So the thing is you're acting out.
Your moral presuppositions,
which you have determined by your own
rules are the ones you should act out.
Then a piece of information pops up its
ugly head suggesting that your means are
wrong,
or in a catastrophic case,
the manner in which you construe the
present or your ends are wrong.
In which case you're.
You're really,
you're really in trouble.
Well,
the question is what?
Then?
What do you do that?
Well,
that's part of what we're going to.
There's,
there's three alternatives.
I think.
One is that you can even just
pretend the anomalous thing never
happened and continue on in your path as
if the world was the way you thought it
was when you know it not to be the case.
That's one.
The other is to actively take measures
to get rid of the anomalous information.
That's a more extreme,
very tough.
That first position.
The second is to give up your whole
moral system and the underground
advantage to that is the normal systems
or hey,
in a sense,
I mean they they have a protective
function certainly,
but to adhere to the means that you have
to discipline your behavior.
So I made a comment in there at one
point about the dark side of of
liberalism as well as many comments
about the dark side of conservatives.
One of the reasons to be extraordinarily
to welcome novel information is so that
you can dissolve all those structures to
which you might have otherwise had to
adhere.
The problem with adhering to those
structures is that it takes a lot of
work,
like if you want to be an optimal member
of any given society.
There's a whole structure of discipline
that's necessary to adhere to and it's
easy to say,
I'm very tolerant when actually what you
mean is I can't tolerate any of this
responsibility.
I'll just let it go and everything's
okay,
but you can get away with that for a
long time because usually you're
protected by other people who are
adhering to the rules and who makes sure
that like the unabomber,
make sure that you stay alive.
So
okay,
well the.
Okay,
so
this argument always loops back onto
itself because the processes are
actually can only be described as in
terms of feedback loop,
so it's very difficult to get a handle
on the origin of the story,
so to say,
so to speak.
But
why would you reject the appearance of
anomalous information?
Say animals don't seem to do that.
While I'm on the argument that I've been
trying to present is that as you pointed
out,
we all have a reason to lie.
She said,
well,
why would you bother on?
His answer was,
well,
because you suffered from it.
That's a good answer.
Well,
now it's a one sentence description of
the process that I was trying to
describe in the chapter on the
development of self consciousness.
The problem for human beings is that
even for animals,
the appearance of an anomalous piece of
information is sufficient to activate
the right frontal cortical circuitry
that governs negative AFLAC.
Sprite and a normal occurrence stops you
in your tracks.
So if you're a rabbit and you're hopping
along the bush and you hear a noise that
shouldn't be there,
or you see a shape that's moving like a
Predator,
what will happen to you?
That's something that should not be.
What will happen to you
is that you will freeze,
right?
Because the systems that govern anxiety
and inhibition of behavior gripped,
gripped your critical apparatus.
Same thing happens in people.
Our first response to an anomalous
event,
it is anxiety and the cessation of
ongoing behavior,
which is exactly how it should be.
Because if an anomalous event occurs,
it's.
It indicates by its very nature that the
plan you were undertaking is wrong.
Because otherwise the anomalous piece of
information wouldn't have showed up.
But the problem with us is that
the whole domain of anomaly,
which can be conceptualized as a place
and is conceptualized that way in
mythology,
is contaminated by our knowledge of the
potential consequences of air and those
consequences.
I mean you can kind of divided into two
camps.
One price of admission of error is that
you have to regard yourself as less than
the group that you identify with it.
Just to say that you look like a fool in
front of people who theoretically you
want respect and admiration.
Prop knows can be actual people or they
can be the people that live in your
head.
So the Super Ego Persona,
persona five doesn't really matter
either way.
It's the same thing.
You have to recognize yourself as less
than you might be.
That's one consequence and people are
very terrified about that.
We don't like exposure of our weaknesses
in front of the social group.
Even Freud pointed out in his
interpretation of dreams,
common anxiety dream was to appear naked
in front of a crowd,
which is basically you could say,
to expose your vulnerability to to the
world or to have that vulnerability
accidentally exposed,
but when you make a fool of someone
that's exactly what you're doing.
It's like they have pretentions which
are there plans.
You just twist them appliance fall and
you see the person behind the plans and
while they turn red and turned away
because their vulnerability has been
made manifest to the group and also
themselves.
It's very unpleasant to occurrence.
That's shaming part,
so that's one reason.
The other reason is that for us,
the whole domain of it normally has a is
contaminated by the threat of mortality,
which is something that's not true for
animals at all because animals can't
conceive of themselves as an object.
That faces is extreme limitations.
The limitations of mortality,
so we have real reason to turn away from
anomaly.
You know,
you want to make it concrete.
For example,
I wake up in the morning,
have an 18 year side
that ache,
which is an anomalous piece of
information since you're always acting
too as a general rule at least maybe if
you worked out at the gym tonight night
before you have already made reasoning
and the ache is bounded by an
explanation and it's an effect of
Valence is basically zero.
I mean you might be able to sniff that
day in favor the side,
but you're not going to walk around in
the state of terror.
If you have already made explanation for
the anomaly,
then there's none.
There's an.
It has an unbounded potential
significance.
Now,
under normal circumstances,
you would like to think,
well,
it doesn't go that serious.
I'll go on with my life and see what
happens.
If your hypochondriacal,
which means that,
well,
it means that you're.
It's easy for you to blow things out of
proportion.
We allow your fantasy too,
which is a hypothesis generating machine
to work on providing potential
explanations for the egg,
which might range from,
I slept wrong too.
This is the incipient incipient sign of
the cancer that will kill me.
I know someone,
for example,
who's father and grandfather both died
of a heart attack when they were in the
neighborhood of 40 and he's 35 and he's
borderline agoraphobic,
which basically means that he can't
tolerate any fluctuations in his heart
rate because that's one of the signs of
anger phobia.
People of anger phobia,
if their heart rate goes up,
they tend to think,
oh no,
this is the event that will either lead
me to make a fool of myself or that will
kill me.
Well,
he's in a situation.
It's pretty much like that all the time
because every time he feels some
unexplained internally then thanks.
That's the end of me.
I could see his.
You can see why he would be neurotic in
a situation like that.
I mean he has good reason for doubting
the intake,
for doubting the easy explanations for
the existence of this anomalous
information because heart disease is
hereditary.
He's a little overweight.
He drinks a little bit too much.
He smokes a little bit too much.
He works too hard.
Is good reason for being afraid,
but that's the sort of thing that the
animals never going to experience
because an animal can't use it's cortex
against it's limbic system in a sense,
which is something we can what your
cortex is supposed to do,
your frontal cortex,
then anomalous piece of information pops
up.
Your frontal cortex is supposed to map
out a behavioral pattern that eliminates
the valence from the phenomenon,
but sometimes you can't do that because
your frontal cortex basically says,
oh no,
this might be the thing that exposes my
weaknesses to the group or kills me,
in which case your limbic system
response to that labeling as if that in
itself is threat and out of control you
go,
which I think is an explanation for
panic attacks,
for example,
catastrophic reasoning,
but everybody has.
For me,
the x,
for me,
the mystery of panic attacks is more why
people just don't have the time really,
really,
because the people who haven't had good
reason for having them,
but those reasons are very much like the
reasons that we all have,
so
we're lucky is the answer.
I think under most circumstances,
fine.
We're protected by our implicit theories
of belief,
it systems of belief,
and most of us,
I suppose we're taught as children.
If a minor physical anomaly arises that
the best course of action is to carry on
at least as a motive hypothesis testing
and that's affordable for lots of
acquired adaptations.
Sounds awesome.
Willing to consider explanations might
be what?
Well,
that's what sure,
and that's one of the things you teach
in cognitive behavioral therapy,
which is.
But the thing is most of us are lucky
you see with most people who are
neurotic,
if you provide them with an alternative
explanation that day five,
it has no impact whatsoever on their
symptomatology.
So you take someone who has obsessive
compulsive disorder,
for example,
camp which is often manifested in fear
of contamination.
So here's the line of logic.
There was a garbage can,
garbage cans are dirty,
dirt contains bacteria.
Bacteria might kill me or worse my
children.
So this is an example going from a case
that I know were university educated
woman.
Nothing wrong with your intelligence,
perfectly normal,
unless she was encountered something
that was contaminated.
You do response prevention treatment,
which is that you have personally
encountered the thing that if you're the
most dependent,
stopped him from doing their habitual
response passage,
which for her was washing her hands
until they were so raw,
they were shiny anyways.
Um,
she thought that there was a possibility
that if she encountered something that
was contaminated,
which was a category that gotten broader
and broader as her disease progressed,
did she carry home and disease to her
children?
Um,
problem.
See,
the problem with that line of reasoning
is that it's possible and yeah,
you could say to her and she could
understand that the probability of such
an event occurring was virtually zero,
but the fact of virtually zero was not
sufficiently satisfying for that to calm
her because point zero,
zero,
zero one percent was too much.
So you couldn't rationally reduce the
probability to,
to a small enough degree so that her
thought of that probability could
regulate your emotions.
And the only reason we don't know why,
those sorts of thoughts regulate our
emotions.
So you're willing to accept it on faith
for whatever reason you jumped in the
car.
Do all sorts of things that are
dangerous without any real
consideration.
I knew another woman who was an
agoraphobic first thing she used to do
when she went into any new building when
she didn't like doing.
Let's check out little fire escapes.
Why it might be a fire,
right?
There might be a fire.
What's the profitability?
Lots of low.
She knew that.
She knew that the probability was low
just like the rest of us know,
but the capacity of that information to
inhibitor anxiety was gone.
The only thing you can do under those
circumstances is actually have people
act out,
not caring.
Then then then that works.
Some people argue that her
rationalization,
that behavior is something that comes
after her behavior in that something
that causes in other words is it isn't
necessarily it.
Couldn't it be one of two things?
Either she she will interest the
building and things.
My my dentist,
there can be fire,
I have to check fire escapes or maybe
she walked into a building or anxiety
rises and she says,
I have to check.
Sure,
sure.
That's possible.
Some of these explanations or post hoc
rationalizations and it's hard to tell
like I'm not trying to specify a causal
sequence.
What happens in Andrew Phobia I think is
the behavioral avoidance takes
precedence over the cognitive
rationalization,
whatever they are,
but how does the agoraphobic,
because they go to the mall,
something frightening happens and they
run away.
Now it's the running away that
constitutes the point of origin for the
pathology.
Now they may say,
I ran away because you know,
here's my set of cognitive
rationalizations.
Many of which might be post hoc
explanations for my behavior,
but the thing is when you run from
something,
what you are doing regardless of what
your thinking is,
labeling it as something so frightened
that I have to run away from and that's
the most profound level of labeling that
you can actually utilize it much more
real than it will.
The secondary or even tertiary semantic
labeling that we usually associate with
categorization to run from something
means to categorize it as too
frightening to be to bear and also one
more thing.
It also means to categorize yourself,
and this is even more important as
something that's so small that in that
situation the only thing that can be
done is to run away,
but the reason that the exposure therapy
works is probably mostly because it.
It counters that latter argument,
which is that when you,
when you teach someone exposure,
when you use exposure to help someone
overcome their fears,
what you were doing is teaching them
that they're not so small.
That fear will devour them and that's
what causes the generalization.
It's learning that.
So can you tell us a profound social
expectation in a situation?
Absolutely,
absolutely no.
Or that the therapist uses social
pressure and everything else to to
foster the notion that the person can
withstand the exposure.
Okay.
Can I just translate something benefit
that I,
that I seem to be hearing in a sense
from what you said today so far,
if,
if I May,
it seems as if the thing that for Texas
from ethology,
the ability to,
to attribute and multiple meanings to
something that the ability that our
prefrontal cortex gives us is the same
thing.
That can cause a problem also,
you've got a conflict and absolutely,
absolutely.
The thing about any religious myths,
for example,
myths of the fall state fundamentally
that the development of self
consciousness which is associated with
tremendous expansion of cortical ability
plus the ability to model the self as an
object precipitated that catastrophe and
emotional catastrophe,
but the cure for the catastrophe is more
of the same disease,
right?
So it's the problem is that a little
self consciousness is terrible.
A lot however,
might might be redemptive and that's the
notion that underlies,
that underlies all sorts of redemptive
mythologies and that's the notion that's
underlying the argument that I'm trying
to elaborate up today because if you
know enough about yourself,
then the consequences of a of a narrow
self consciousness can be removed.
And I would say,
well,
what myths are trying to teach you as if
they're trying to teach you something,
which they're really not.
I mean,
they're just,
they're.
What they're trying to teach you is that
your normal conception of who you are is
much too narrow.
Now you know at some level you know
that's true because you're modeling
yourselves wrong obviously because
you're too complex for yourself
tomorrow.
It's like no one thinks that they have
an accurate model of cosmological
processes and it's certainly arguable
that the processes that make up each of
us as individuals are complex at a level
that's exponentially greater than any
cosmological process that we could
possibly conceive of.
So the notion that your model of
yourself is inaccurate.
That's just a statement of fact.
The part that's not so factual is how
you can get valid information to
increase the breadth of that model.
What I'm basically trying to point out
is that mid you can do that is with
Amanda,
is a large part,
is our accumulated attempt to construct
a story that accounts for our behavior
in the world.
We watch ourselves act and derive
conclusions.
As a consequence,
your entire life is a lie and everything
bad that happens to you,
even though you recognize it,
it's bad and you're miserable
outside cause I never resigned with
yourself.
What?
What's intrinsically rewarding about
lying to yourself?
If you know that you're making yourself
miserable because look,
any defined terror is better than any
undefined terror because it defined
terror has a boundary and an undefined.
Tara has none,
and that's the law.
Here's an example.
There's been some reliable studies of
late that indicate that gay men who
engage in high risk behavior for aids
are less anxious after being diagnosed
with aids than they were before
because the possibility the possibility
is worse than the actuality.
No matter how bad the actuality is,
possibility is worse.
So what about if your product because of
pride and not fear,
like if
it's just.
I think those that that's always the
case as far as I've been able to
determine.
It's not.
That's why I said you can't say this is
just one thing.
These things conglomorate together,
but people that I've dealt with who were
severely neurotic enough so that their
whole life was a lie and literally it
was pride as well that was stopping them
from letting go.
They wouldn't say,
well look,
you understand?
For example,
he treated one patient who had an
obsessional neurosis that lasted 20
years.
He said,
I cannot reconcile myself to the fact
that I wasted two years.
So you think of what that admission
requires.
You know,
you have a finite time and if you've
blown,
not only have you blown out a big chunk
of it,
but in the course of blowing it out you,
you've added to the cumulative misery of
the world.
You know,
lots of people who are non physically,
physiologically unhealthy use their
neurotic misery to manipulate others
around them to their own ends,
to make people feel guilty,
to get them to do what they want because
they don't think they can just come
right out and say,
you know,
would you please do this?
They have to manifest some sign of
weakness so that they force other people
to take care of.
All of that has to come up and be
admitted before you can step away from
this situation.
What was Satan afraid of eternity like
you had nothing more to lose everything
to gain because it,
sorry.
Groups and gets gotten sucked back into
heaven.
Like where did pride become fear for
Satan in paradise lost.
I can't answer.
I don't know.
Like I don't know enough to answer that
question specifically.
I mean,
the only thing I can,
the only thing I can say about that is
that these processes feedback onto one
another.
I mean
the more low.
Okay,
let me go through this argument to some
degree and maybe it'll.
Maybe it'll shed a little bit of light
on that question.
Okay.
What happens?
What's the consequence of injection of
air?
While we know that before you can engage
in any sort of creative exploration,
you have to at least admit that
something went wrong and so you say,
well,
there's something wrong with my and let
some level of analysis.
That's the admission.
Then the next process is to engage in
some sort of creative exploration,
which is basically the generation of
hypothesis and they're testing.
You find out you made someone upset,
for example,
accidentally,
well then you think,
well,
maybe this was wrong with my approach,
and then we talked to them first about
that.
See if that was right in.
If that wasn't,
throw it out.
Hypothesis to side.
Pick up another one and act it out and
see if you get the information you want,
so on and so forth to get the answer and
let's create an exploration.
Say,
well,
what happens as a consequence of
creative exploration?
Well,
look,
remember we talked about symbols of the
chaos that existed prior to the creation
of the world,
so to speak.
That chaos was symbolized by the dragon
as a general rule is composed of the
union of all things that are now often
it's the source of all things,
not just objects,
but subjects as well.
So it's everything that we see as
distinct,
melded into some paradoxical unity,
and that stands for the unknown.
As such.
Now Piaget said,
when children that children construct
themselves as a consequence of their
creative exploration,
which basically means that the child
doesn't know anything about the world,
it's a very bounded domain of knowledge.
What it does is encountered the vast,
I've known explore,
generate information,
and now that information constructs
itself as a subject which means grants
itself a self and also the world as an
objective reality.
So that's what the notion that chaos
also contains.
The subject means that as you gathering
like you build yourself out of the
information you generated in the process
of exploration,
have you stopped exploring?
Although that has obvious conclusions,
it doesn't.
It means you start building yourself.
We already know that a system that stops
growing because everything around the
system changes of its own accord decays
over time,
and we know what the decay means.
He's life comes to a standstill and the
negative forces that are underneath
order rise up.
So that story basically says,
reject anomaly.
Personality stops developing.
Then you're in the kingdom that's coming
to a standstill where everything's
paralyzed.
There's no water and everything's dying.
Well,
what that means is that the mere fact of
not progressing means that you go
backwards and your life becomes well as
those debt,
a desert,
nothing grows in the desert.
Everything's unbearable there.
So you say if you reject the possibility
of growth,
what necessarily occurs is that all
that's left for you is a life that gets
worse and worse and worse,
worse,
worse.
Now,
if your life goes from bad to worse,
over time,
we know already.
This is just addresses the comment you
made last week.
You punish an animal,
you make me.
That's one way of making meaning
anyways.
If you construct your relationship with
the world such that over time the
likelihood is that everything will go
from bad to worse.
The other consequences of that is that
your attitude towards you existing Cisco
and go from bad to worse as well,
saying,
well,
why do people are people consumed with
hatred and a desire for revenge,
which has played out completely milk
story.
Once Satan determines that admission of
error is completely out of the question,
he turns his attention to taking revenge
on existence.
I'm trying to trying to provide an
explanation for why that's a necessary
consequence of this because if you stop,
if you eliminate a priority and
necessity for further deny yourself the
possibility of positive change and
adaptation,
the necessary consequence of that is
increased personal,
suffered,
and that it's a very likely given that
you're narrowing your personality,
which means you get weaker and weaker is
very,
very likely under those circumstances
that you're going to become more and
more full of revenge because life's so
unfair after all and hatred because
you're always being tortured even though
you're doing it to yourself.
We the rationalization is why do all
these terrible things constantly happen
to me?
It must either be that everyone's
against me.
This is a perfectly common hypothesis,
or the conditions of existence itself
are so unbearable that everything should
be eradicated,
which as we talked about last week,
is the essential.
That's the essential Credo
Mephistopheles,
right?
The world is so intrinsically so
unbearable that the only proper course
of action is to work for it.
So elimination.
How last week I tried to tie that into
stalins reasoning.
Basically.
Yes,
that's what it looks to me like.
That was the philosophy that
characterizes step.
Everyone's against me,
that's for sure.
He was a real paranoid
and he worked throughout his life to
continually develop his capacity to
destroy larger and larger swaths of
people.
I don't think there's much difference
really.
See,
I think like this is not always the case
because suicide is motivated by all
sorts of different reasons,
but it's certainly the case and I said I
think this is particularly true about
adolescent suicide is that it's an act
of revenge because.
Well it and it also is an illustration
of how deep the motivation for revenge
can be because adolescents,
suicidal fantasies are often go along
the lines of old.
All those people be sorry when I'm gone,
and then there's a whole fantasy about
how the funeral rule progress in all
these people who paid in sufficient
attention or being otherwise cruel will
file by and think about all the terrible
things they did.
So on and so forth.
And while the truth of the truth of the
matter is that a suicide leaves a hole
in a community that can be reconciled
because the people who are leftover are
always faced with the question of why
did this happen?
And also what could I have done about
it,
both of which are essentially
unanswerable.
So
the question that you're posing to some
degree,
this is one murder worse than a million
for it.
And I would say that they don't some in
a sense just as just as you are,
society is predicated on the idea that
every individual is of incalculable
worth when you can't.
One thing of incalculable worth is worth
as much as 20 things of incalculable
work.
So it's not.
It's not an additive.
Phenomenal.
Sorry,
I think you were saying sort of thing.
The vengeful aspect motivates both.
The Newman Newman conceptualized suicide
is he felt that was the mythological
explaining.
Explination was regressive wish for
incest with the great mother,
which is a very awkward way of saying,
if only I was gone,
if only I banished back to the point
that I had come from.
Then all of these problems that I'm
faced with would just disappear and
that's also something that's character
and newman imagined that to census,
an attractive force pulling someone down
below the earth,
so that's just a desire for death as a,
as a solution to the problems of life.
You can also say these things are
complicated.
Maybe you can also say that you thought
that the collective unconscious produced
conference Satori fantasies,
which basically meant that if your
conscious mind,
so to speak,
which was in part,
your linguistically constructed itself,
was failing to take certain
possibilities into account than the
collective unconscious,
which you might think about as
manifesting itself in fantasies that you
really can't control.
It just pop up like fantasies of death.
For example.
Often,
although they may have a pathological
aspect,
they also hold out at least in
possibility the seeds of a cure because
you could say,
well,
if you were here
and you're convinced that this is
unbearable,
the notion that a death is necessary is
a first order attempt to hypothesize
that the thing that constrains your
interpretation of meaning should
disappear.
Which is to say that the fact that your
life has become so twisted that you
regard it as unbearable is evidence that
your motive interpretation is so
outdated that it should die.
No,
that's a perfectly reasonable answer.
Sacrificial Motif for,
and I read the other day,
I didn't know this,
that the idea of sacrificing of fingers,
very common throughout our camp
mythology.
I didn't know that my finger is
something that's very important.
That's the same idea as a sacrifice of a
virgin sacrifice of heroes.
That if things are unbearable,
you either have to kill what's making it
unbearable so that something new can
come into being.
That's one mode of the sacrificial
hometeam,
but the other thing is is another thing
that underlies the sacrificial is the
idea of the exposure of the hero to the
forces of the unknown.
That's great.
That's another segment
on that diagram.
Just one.
It doesn't matter.
You know,
basically we about suicide.
It's like returning to the source of,
all right,
turn into the world,
right?
Because that,
that unconscious chaos that precedes
existence has a paradise aspect,
right?
Because there's no tension of opposites
there,
which basically means there's just no
being at all,
but which could be a relief knew under
certain conditions.
So
is that it?
I'm just saying within that framework,
is that.
Would you say that's heading into chaos
or is that going back a long time?
Well,
it depends.
You see,
if you move from border,
like where's,
where's the source of all things?
Where's the break?
Can we put the great mother?
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
No problem.
This is anomalous information here.
So you say,
well,
chaos is not known as such.
He never encountered that because you
always encounter things that are more or
less within a determinant framework.
You never see what you don't understand
and its entirety,
or maybe that occurs to people who are
having some sort of mystical experience.
Mostly what you see are things that you
can somewhat define that pop up in your
day to day experience.
Those are actual anomalous pieces of
information that you have some
definitional handle on what the great
mother would be.
The story
you can think of,
the great mother as the agent of chaos,
which is a perfectly reasonable the way
look at it because in the mythological
progression,
she's the first offs right there.
Okay,
good.
The original chaos separates into the
great mother in the grateful on.
Alright,
so she is the first child of chaos.
Subset essentially of class.
She's the form of the form.
That chaos takes in your actual
experience.
So wouldn't it be more effort in that
diagram to say the chaos there is really
the great mother because what do you
start going back?
Well,
you have talking about that.
That's where the entire diagram comes
from because that's the world split into
it's conduct.
It's complicated because for example,
many figures of the great mother have a
snake wrapped around.
Well,
that's because the.
The association between the Dragon of
chaos in the great mother is very,
very close.
So to say this is the great mother is
true,
but it's not just that.
It's also the origin of the great father
and also the origin of the hero.
So the mythological figures are
contaminated by each other because
they're north tight category,
so lots of like the Gorgon is another
example.
Great mother.
Her hair is snakes,
which is representative of chaos.
Now when you look at her,
you turned to stone,
which means be terrified.
So she's an agent of chaos.
But chaos is more like that.
That first order category is more than
just the kind of normally that you
encountered during your day to day life.
It's the source of everything.
So it's outside the whole process.
Okay.
I was just saying,
I mean I know that this symbol is mesh
together on that level,
but if we're,
if we're bringing them into a more
systematic framework,
yeah.
Then to to kill yourself,
you will eliminate the self entirely.
It would essentially be to send yourself
into if you're nothing,
what,
where everything came.
Right?
Right.
Exactly.
So which is somewhat different from what
you encounter if that.
If that is the diagram of the way we
encountered life,
then
I would say that the things that make
you desire a return to nothingness are
the the actual anomalous phenomenon,
threatening for the women that you've
encountered,
like the sum total of all of them.
So it's repeated appearances of
intolerable information produced within
you.
The desire to advantage basically.
So
anyways,
the fingers,
the fingers are contaminated.
That's why time at,
for example,
in the,
in the Mesopotamian myth,
I mean absolute.
He's known in the Mesopotamian myth,
right?
The concert,
he gets very little press and that story
is not for lions devoted to you.
The gods killing your stupid me,
and of course the anti map rises up,
right?
Because he's the thing that protected
them,
but that's all that's known about.
Hammerhead timeout is female and the
wife of absent and the mother of Marta,
but she's also the serpent,
the mindset,
the bottom of the ocean.
That's the mother of everything,
the source of everything.
So there you can see the overlap between
the mythological domain.
She's female,
but she's also.
She lives at the bottom of the ocean.
So
derive is a notion of what suicide was
based on the fantasies for people who
may come down to commit suicide or did
he just follow a train of reasoning to
decide that suicide was designed for?
I don't know that I don't know the
details of the conclusion he came to.
He wasn't practicing therapist.
Is it possible he got so excited about
the system that he was pulling together?
Sure.
That's always possible.
That's all.
It's just,
it's more a story.
It's more a way of looking at the
situation.
Maybe it's not.
It's not unreasonable to suppose that
people who commit suicide,
wish for the cessation of their
experience been since.
That's what suicide producers as well as
a lot of general,
a lot of misery on the part of people
left behind one of the like there's the
psychoanalytic,
this is a human Erickson actually a
okay.
If you can't tell what motivates that
behavior,
look at the effects.
The effects are the are motivated.
How you can say that's a pretty extreme
position.
It is an extreme position,
but they'll tell you if your partner of
your own life that produces very
interesting consequences at least as a
heuristic.
Like you can say,
no,
that's not always true.
Fine.
It's not always true,
but if you do something and it has a
certain effect and you say,
well,
I didn't intend that effect and you ask
why did I do that?
A first order hypothesis.
The hypothesis is I did intend that,
but I didn't know.
And if you follow that line of
reasoning,
if you can,
well it can have some have very salutary
effects,
especially if the thing that you didn't
intend has happened like two or three
times because then it's.
There's some indication that of
complicity.
It's only one occurrence.
Well,
you know,
mistakes happen,
but if it keeps happening to you.
Lucky I think the other state was,
if it's pointing a gun at you,
it's likely that it wants to shoot the
same sort of idea and that was in
reference to the Cold War.
Why were people conspiring to build
weapons,
to destroy the world?
While the simple maybe too simple
explanation is on some level that was
the intent,
but I buy that argument was certainly
appeared to be 10th.
I mean,
he was practicing it all the time.
Now the question is how much was that?
The intent of the West?
Well,
that's not an answerable yet,
but I would suspect to a large degree,
does that apply to other people's
behavior?
Well,
it's dangerous to apply it to other
people's behavior,
but
it isn't the principal that I rely on as
an absolute explanation,
but it's a useful hypothesis.
Especially like I said,
the same thing keeps happening.
See you,
Elizabeth.
You made the point,
you know,
neurotic people will find themselves
trapped in in misery that they recognize
clearly is misery without stepping
outside of it,
and I would say well that that fact
indicates that they prefer the misery
they have to the possibilities and they
don't have to.
It's the only way to explain.
It's not the only way to explain
anything,
but it's one way of accounting for the
fact of resistance in psychotherapy,
the underground where the point is made
that separate is fun.
It gets attention.
That's,
that's,
that's the secondary gain hypothesis.
That's it's an effective manipulative
strategy has all sorts of self
reinforcing a side effects.
I mean that's why it occurs.
Rejection of anomalies is very
negatively reinforcing.
That's one of the reasons why it's while
it has this attracted aspect,
so if you don't attend to all those
things that indicate that you're in
error,
I mean to the degree that you're
successful and no one attending to them,
you're not anxious,
you're not depressed,
you're not confused,
you know,
but the problem is all that information
that you don't process first of all
isn't transformed by you into something
usable and second bull as far as I've
been able to tell.
It accumulates over time and then what
happens to you is that in a year are
getting smaller and smaller just because
that's the way things work.
Basically if you stagnate,
you get sicker and sicker and the things
that you yourself have labeled as
threatening because when you refuse to
process something,
what you're saying or what you're doing
is that thing is terrible for me to
contemplate.
So what you're doing is transforming
chunks of the world into the category of
those things that are too terrifying to
come to conflict or you're leaving them
in that category,
which is a more accurate way of looking
at it.
Sooner or later you're this high and the
world that you've transformed into
threat is everywhere around you and it's
only a matter of time until you're weak
enough so that the whole thing falls in
on you.
Is there a difference between ignoring
it and just interpreting it in such a
way like the positive bias but don't
know where nothing was ever your fault
and like you're the martyr.
Like anything bad that happens to you is
because there's some evil force out
there that we're.
You're kind of taking it in,
only putting such a spin on it that
you're saying,
here's this unknown thing.
I'm making it known,
but labeling it wrong on purpose that
way.
Well,
that's just a.
that's just a variant of the same theme,
but it accumulates well,
but I think
it's a.
it's a feedback mechanism.
That's right.
There's a feedback mechanism at work,
so you get smaller and smaller.
You a new mislabeled the problem or.
Well,
actually I think really what you're
doing is that you're not pulling the
label off it because we already know
that anomalous information manifests
itself is threat.
It's right.
That's how your right frontal cortex
works.
Basically mistake comes up in the form
of threat.
That's how it's indicated on them,
so it's already labeled as threat.
Your job when you explore is to
transform the threat into something
irrelevant or something beneficial north
to merely label it as something
different,
but to actually change it by altering
your behavior into something that's
usable.
If you don't do that well,
then what's happening is that the
determinant world transforms itself back
into terrifying chaos and you're just
failing to stop that from happening.
It'll do that all by itself,
but by labeling it an evil force,
you've made an effort to get rid of
forest and everybody making it even
more.
That's true.
That's certainly at least worse for
others,
and I would say,
well,
yes,
yes.
Oh,
that's right.
I mean,
but there's more motivation to that
because as you're weakening yourself and
your hatred for life grows,
your desire for revenge accelerates.
So then if you could take the next step
and say,
well,
not only is this anomalous information
intolerable,
but it's evil,
then I can kill it.
Well then you've got everything set
because you can remove the source of
your trouble.
You can act out your hostile fantasies
and you can feel justified because
you're patriotic or which is all
rubbish.
Um,
yeah.
It's like,
no,
you're talking about stuff and the world
is so terrible that it must be
destroyed.
Is it possible to distinguish that from
like the world is so terribly fascism of
it must be destroyed,
are?
Yes,
I would say.
Sure.
Absolutely.
That's distinguishable because one of
the hallmarks of the hero,
and this is something that the night I
was at pains to outline in the latter
part of the manuscript is the hero has
two functions.
One is to transfer,
transform,
unexplored territory into explored
territory which is just Marta battle
against time,
but also to update the social structure
which has both manifested internally and
externally as that becomes necessary,
so the pro.
Now we know the problem with updating a
social structure is that sometimes that
takes on a revolutionary aspect and then
for all the adherence of that social
structure who were either going and
forest revolution,
that heroic activity is going to seem
like a demonic demonic force and that's
why people are so irritated inheritance
because they pop up the normalist
information and for good reason.
I mean careless hermeticism is very,
very dangerous because it produces
schismatic activity and break societies
down,
but it also,
it's like a genetic mutation that's the
best.
That's the best metaphor.
I know it's like a 999 revolutions are
counterproductive,
but the one revolution in the thousand
dollars isn't counterproductive,
is absolutely necessary and the problem
is how do you distinguish between the
two?
I mean,
if you just use the odds,
the first thing you'd say is all
revolutionary shouldn't be regarded.
The skepticism like extreme skepticism,
but not skepticism to the point where a
priority they should be eliminated
because one of them just quite the.
Well,
it just might be the hero.
So
I,
I'm,
I'm still trying to translate what
you're talking about into sort of a
parallel framework and what I was just
thinking of is there might be two ways
to change the social system.
One by coming back as a caring,
advocating.
Okay.
The way things should be telling people
what beliefs you're placing,
they have.
The other thing is to come back changed,
right?
Right,
right.
Then with.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then your relationships with other
people change.
Well that's,
that's,
that's the sort of the sort of path that
the.
Well,
that I want to outline in more detail
next week because one,
I think one,
one piece of evidence that should
justify skepticism is the overt desire
of the revolutionary to maintain their
position at all cost and to transport
everyone around them because then you
think,
was that revolution or is that,
is that fascism masquerading as
revelation?
Which it almost always is.
So like a communist ideologue,
he wants to transform a capitalist
society.
Isn't the revolutionary just he's just a
fascist on the left wing.
There's no heroism map,
but I guess I suppose the other thing
that one might be skeptical of his
revolutionaries in groups because that's
sort of a contradiction in terms,
right?
So not always for either of those,
but that's still a sign I would say,
but I think that the notion of coming
back change,
that's the issues.
I think what these myths are trying to
point out is that the only permanently
effective form of social revolution is a
personal revolution and then just acts
itself out where that social change is
just a necessary consequence of that
personal change.
It isn't something that's being enforced
or even planned out to a degree.
It's just
let me know.
That strikes me,
is
that what strikes me as a justifiable
position,
at least then you're also much less
likely to make catastrophic errors
because your primary concern is always,
what am I doing wrong?
Or here's the situation,
how am I contributing to it?
Not,
you know,
where are all the bad people?
Who are really causing more trouble,
so I mean I knew lots of this is kind of
a sarcastic comment I guess,
and I knew lots of environmental
activists in graduate school who may be
filthy apartments.
It's like they couldn't even keep their
personal territory clean and yet they
were willing to engage in activities
that in terms of their own fantasies,
had the potential impact of
restructuring society.
Practice what you preach.
Well,
at least.
Yeah.
At least at least act it out so that you
can see on your own territory,
one if it works,
and two,
if you can actually even acted out.
So the thing is,
while you know there's a lot nip,
funny mythological statements,
like the man who rules himself is,
has,
has a.
I don't know the quote precisely.
The man who rose himself has performed a
more difficult task than the man who
wrote the city.
It's hard to rule a city,
but what it means is it is actually.
The truth is you're much more
complicated phenomenon than a city.
And to bring yourself under some sort of
control is much more difficult than.
It's more difficult than bringing the
given social structure under control
because the social structure assemble,
Harrison plus,
it's also equivalent to bringing in
social structure and control because
what you're composed of in large part is
the sum total of social structures.
Now they as they be generated over a
neck stretches of time,
so inside you,
for example,
like if you want to reconcile the
abortion debate,
that's an internal reconciliation as
well.
You have to rethink the philosophical
presuppositions
sufficiently deep enough so that you
come to a solution that brings the two
sides together.
That can hold,
take place inside before it takes place
outside.
Go past it
at some level.
The most powerful social movements bring
these two things together.
I'm like the,
I'm not drinking in the early days of
solidarity,
which is one of the things that really
impressed me about it.
It was the way it translated to,
of personal transformation or the way in
which the civil rights movement evolved
in this country requiring a personal
change,
uh,
which was through it in a collective way
created social change or in the women's
movement.
I mean,
in other words,
it seems like in these genuine social
movements,
change occurs both in the macro and
micro level.
They're brought in consonance with one
another.
Well,
I mean,
that's,
that strikes me at least as a plausible
hypothesis,
you know,
um,
I remember,
George Orwell,
right?
He was,
he started out as a socialist
ideologically,
but then,
well,
one of the things that transformed him
from a mere idea log into a writer of
note and a political commentator of note
was that he decided,
he,
he noted that in his experience,
most academic socialists weren't all
that fond of the poor.
This was particularly true in Britain
where there a higher class structure,
so they were from the upper classes and
acted out there detests than the lower
classes in all their action patterns
while holding the ideological belief
that the poor were in fact,
morally superior.
Somewhat.
Orwell did was,
well,
he went to Paris and London and lived in
Paris among dishwashers and in in Great
Britain among traps and coal miners,
forcing himself to overcome what he soon
recognized was a very deep set prejudice
against everything that the poor
represented well.
Then what happened to her well was he
dropped his socialism very rapidly
because he found that the ideological
structure was nowhere near profound
enough to encompass what he'd
experienced.
Plus it had enormously dangerous side
effects,
which he increasingly came to recognize.
So maybe,
I mean maybe that's a.
maybe that's because one of the things
that everyone would like to figure out
is like how do you distinguish a
pathological revolution from a valid
revolution?
And I mean I would say if you're asking
someone else to bear more of the costs,
then you're actually bearing.
Then that's one sign that it's.
That there's some sort of pathology at
the bottom of it,
who knows,
but that seems like a reasonable first
approximation.
So I guess you also have to see like who
gets what out of it?
The communist revolution as far as I've
been able to determine,
just replaced one tyrannical group that
at least we're,
we're bound by tradition with another
tyrannical group that were completely
unbound by tradition and,
and even more tyrannical
because the problem was,
is that
the only reason
the Russian revolutionaries were more
moral than the tsar was because they
didn't have any power.
They couldn't do anything.
So when they look to themselves more,
I'm harmless.
I mean,
I've put anybody in prison.
Of course they don't have a prison,
but when they got prisons they certainly
put lots of people.
Hang on.
So
what other comments,
Daniel?
No.
Okay.
So
yeah.
Okay.
So we basically got to this point in the
argument now,
which you doing?
Oh,
I'm just outlining this argument so that
I don't forget where I am.
Basically it goes like this over here.
Okay.
So the question is how to get out of
this.
I mean,
if we're willing to take nature,
if notion seriously,
which is that everyone has sufficient
reason to lie.
Then the question is,
given that as a premise,
the conclusion is perhaps to a much
larger degree than we believe.
We're lying to ourselves.
Now,
one of the thing,
shelley Taylor,
she's the social psychologist who's been
promoting this positive self delusion
notion.
One of the valuable things she's done,
I think was although I don't think she
drew the right conclusion from it,
was that she noted that many people who
we regard as normal and healthy in fact
erect around themselves,
barriers of positive illusions.
Now she drew from that the conclusion
that to be normal and healthy,
well first of all,
the normal people were healthy,
which is.
I have a real problem with that,
but I mean you can see.
You can see how that necessarily emerges
as a consequence of psychological
methodology in a sense because okay,
I made the argument to begin within the
class that as soon as you apply a field
like psychology or medicine,
you're out of the domain of science and
into the domain of morality because you
have to make judgments about what
constitutes the good if you have to now,
but people who are in the domain of
science don't like to admit that,
so they try to figure out ways to
determine what's moral scientifically
without ever having to address the
problem.
And the easiest way to do that is by
saying,
well,
here's the normal distribution,
right?
The optimal level is the midpoint.
So you take the average person,
you see how many positive sell solutions
they have around.
When you say those average people,
they're normal.
That defines healthy.
Therefore positive self lesions are
necessary,
but this is like this is a real problem
because first of all,
many things that are average,
we don't consider ideal.
I mean that's why the two words exist in
opposition.
It was like we know strive for average
intelligence or average athletic ability
or average beauty or average
accomplishment at any level.
We're always moving towards some sort of
ideal anyway,
so I think shelley Taylor got caught and
trapped in a sense she got caught in her
own unconscious presuppositions and
said,
well,
normal people have to be healthy.
By definition,
normal people have lost a part of the
self illusions.
Therefore,
positive self lesions are necessary.
There's lots of flaws in that argument.
I buy the argument that many people who
are considered normal by normal
standards erect barriers of self
positive illusions around themselves,
but the fact that they do that as no
indication whatsoever that is necessary
or desirable because the argument that
I've been trying to outline this whole
course is that
to the degree that the members of the
society,
to the degree that a member or members
of a society erect positive self
illusions around themselves to protect
their normality,
they will make their group pathological.
Pathological it gets.
The more likely it is to do something
terrible.
Other groups,
the sickness is going to come out
somewhere.
Our target,
our timescale analysis in psychology is
something really,
but we don't ever question.
It was like,
you know,
a given phenomenon can have a beneficial
effect at
at the level of analysis of a minute,
a detrimental effect.
If you look at its effect over the
course of a day,
I'm mildly beneficial effect.
If you look at it over the course of a
week,
you know tremendously detrimental effect
if you look at it over the course of a
year in the same thing can have all
sorts of different effects depending on
your parameters of evaluation and
generally psychologists pick one
parameter evaluation and say,
well,
that's representative of the whole
temporal framework and that's just.
It's not a justifiable conclusion.
Say people who are high in self
deception may appear more psychological
help psychologically healthy in the
short term.
If you define psychological health as
the absence of anxiety and depression in
the short term,
but you don't know anything about what
that means for their interpersonal
behavior.
You don't know anything about what that
means.
means for the course of their lifespan
or for the children.
You have no idea what it means for the
relationships with the group or between
groups,
so until you answer all those questions,
you know you have to be pretty careful
about saying about making it as radical
acclaim as self deception is necessary
for psychological.
Can we ask what types of self deception?
Well,
shelley tailoring,
Jonathan Brown.
My understanding is that these are the
types of things that come from making
down comparisons.
So I'm.
I'm better than average.
Yeah.
She said,
she says those are innocuous,
right?
Right.
That's my understanding.
So when asked,
for example,
with you,
ask people to read their ability on the
multitude of trades.
If everybody in this room rated
themselves,
we'd all,
the whole group as a whole would be
above average,
above average.
This is a positive illegitimate.
Thanks Garrison in Wisconsin where every
child is above average,
right?
That's true.
But we can't.
We can't by definition I'll be above
that.
So that sort of definition of positive
illusions,
but isn't it sort of a leap to go from
that type of positive allusion to self
deception that could have
the content of which has to do with your
relationships with other people in the
truths about the world and in all kinds
of other things being where's.
Well it isn't relief because called in
the rewalk has just finished a study on
people who are high in self deception
and found that over the course of a five
year period,
those very people were in fact rated by
their peers as much more dislikable
ended more psychological troubles than
people who are lonely.
So
self deception the same as his.
The people who were thinking that they
above average or are these the same
things?
In other words,
it self deception question sort of self
perception would be the denial of
information.
Positive illusion would be,
yeah,
that hasn't.
That hasn't been completely sorted out
because what if you told this person?
No,
the truth is you are at
and they accepted it.
In other words,
it seems to me that they're looking
slightly different.
Well,
like I said in the literature as as a
whole that hasn't been sorted out.
Even like where we're using one of the
inventories of self deception in our lab
right now,
the trend is sort some of this element.
It's got different.
It's one scale with different factors,
sub categories,
one of which is self enhancement,
which would be more like I'm more than
average and the other ones,
there's two others,
one of which has to do with the denial
of negative information and maybe one of
those is more powerful,
logical,
and maybe one isn't pathological level.
Although I wouldn't bet on,
but I don't know for sure.
I'm just really the difference because
if you say that I.
If you suggest that if you believe that
you are better than you are,
then that means you're not going to
believe you need to fix.
One of the things that we did with this,
by the way,
we've done an experiment with this
questionnaire and we found that people
who are.
He gives these people standard tests of
psychological health.
Well you can't tell because they might
be lying because they lie after all,
neurotic.
Let's say they're not
neurotic,
so what we did was we took,
we took people,
we looked at your tendency to self
enhanced,
we divided them into high sulfur and low
sulfur enhances.
Then we gave them 20 photographs to
rate.
We use the neo five factor personality
more to see how they would rate other
people who were just.
We took a census cross section of race
and niche and then we call and we used
five new adjectives per picture and I
collapsed them all together to kind of
get their average,
their average personality influential
more,
which is imagine you force all those
pictures together.
You get a competent individual,
plus you get a composite personality
score.
People high in self enhancement regard
others as more negative because we put
all the negative adjectives in one
category and all the pauses and another
has more negative than they regard
themselves,
so I would say no,
there's no difference.
The mechanism from the positive
illusions is making downward
comparisons,
which is exactly what these people did,
right?
Well,
call it phone.
The people who do that are rated by
their peers as less,
well,
less socially as worse than people who
don't over the long term short term
advantages,
but that's neuroticism.
That's short term advantage because
that's where people do it.
People also tend to make a comparison to
when they have their sights set,
well this is something that Aaron is
trying to work this out because she
thinks that some of these,
these inventories of self deception are
contaminated with optimism and I think
she's right.
Is that optimistic?
People who think I can make the future
brighter than probability says it is
likely to be,
which I think is a perfectly reasonable
stance and is dependent on your ability
to work.
She thinks those people get lumped
together with the self deceivers proper
because if they took as their reference
group one level of accomplishment that I
think I can do better for myself.
Right,
right.
Well a lot of this has to be pulled
apart compared to their peers.
Right?
Absolutely.
I mean,
and it's not all that easy to pull out a
positive belief in the future and its
possibilities from.
I've already got that positive future
now,
even though all the evidence suggests
that the contrary is true,
so that's right.
A fantasy about how good things might be
is not necessarily pathological unless
you presume that things are already that
way.
In fact,
you need it.
He needed a fantasy like that to keep
you going ahead.
So
which is exactly what we're talking
about.
Well,
here's another example.
We ran an experiment because we're very
interested in this particular line of
research because it contradicts
everything that I'm trying to say in
this course.
So that personally irritates me as well
as I,
you know,
for all sorts of other reasons.
I just can't believe that shelly
Taylor's writing like 5,000 years of
religious traditions gathered from all
over the world are wrong.
Just strikes me as highly unlikely.
Anyways,
test that has been used to discriminate
psychopaths from non psychopathic.
No.
So think about psychopaths is that while
they're not very pleasant to be around
in the term,
although superficially they can be very
charming.
In fact,
they make a study of how to be charming.
if you do group therapy with second
perhaps,
which is very bad idea,
they become more effective psychopaths
because they pick up the whole
psychological vocabulary and an array of
professional techniques that they would
never otherwise have access to.
So anyways,
they're not very anxious and depressed,
but they're also dangerous,
you know,
was a test that has been used to
distinguish psychopaths from non second
pass.
It's called the Newman card playing
task.
Daniel computerized it up for use in
this study.
It consists of an extinction paradigm.
None of you are going to take this.
You might
mean
well knowing it depends.
You can't take it.
If you listen to this,
you probably shouldn't take it anyways
because he'd been in this course,
so you'll kind of know what the hell's
going on possibly.
So you wouldn't be a good subject.
Okay.
So stay out of my anyways.
Anyway,
so.
Okay,
so you have 100 cards and they're
stacked.
The deck is staff and in the first deck
there's 10 cards and their face cards,
every time you turn around and face you
get a quarter,
you start with someone,
and then in the next deck of 10 the
subject doesn't know this one out of 10
of the cars makes you lose randomly and
in the next day,
two of the 10 make you news.
Then three,
10,
four,
five,
and so on.
All the way until the end.
We're a 10 out of 10.
Make loose,
lose.
Now the your instructions are.
Do you ever ring again?
Nope.
It's an extinction paradigm.
So you mean the first time you went you
went in for the first 50 percent of the
right because you went 10 times,
then you went nine.
Then you have the
cards,
either winners or losers.
Now all you have to do is segway to
stop.
Now the object is to maximize your
money.
Obviously.
Well,
high self deceivers make half as much
money as low self to seniors because
they don't know when to quit and I think
the reason they don't know when to quit
is because
losing is indication of error.
It's labeled with negative apnic.
That's what stops you.
If you have essentially ignore all signs
of there.
Well you're not gonna stop doing
something stupid as fast as you should.
So anyways,
they make half as much money's low,
self deceived.
So wait,
I'm sorry,
I don't understand.
So they keep going longer than they
should,
but do you.
You start losing money or just stop
winning every time.
One of these sort.
And maybe my explanation was confusing.
Yeah.
You either wait a quarter or lose a
quarter.
That's right.
Right.
So the ratio of wins,
two losses decreases over time
and you should stop somewhere in the 50
slash 50 range,
right?
Or maybe a little after that because
whatever.
But somewhere around there,
when you're losing as often as you're
winning and you can see the numbers
total up on the screen and the quarters
appear or disappear.
So you can tell when you hit the
maximum.
So then that seems to be complicated
with the optimism variable
because if somebody just thinks,
well I'm just kidding,
keep going,
you know,
well it's,
it's conceivable.
It's like this is,
this is a hard thing to factor out and
it's conceivable if it's contaminated by
optimism,
I would say that I'm to the
circumstance.
So the test optimism is unwarranted past
a certain point.
So to be up and you'd have to assume
that isn't stacked and therefore it came
back.
But since the things that decreasing
incrementally one by one and when you're
going to figure out pretty quickly that
it was set up,
well,
yeah.
Well that's,
that's the hope is you figure it out.
That's right.
Stop in.
Lots of things in life are like that.
I mean,
you know,
to do something and it's working,
it's working and then it doesn't work so
well and then it works even less well
than you know.
Sooner or later you should quit.
Now obviously that can be contaminated,
that fight persistence.
The other thing we get,
and you have these people put their
finger in a pain device,
minor league paid device you need is
just a.
it's just a lever.
It's kinda about a sharp dull butter
knife and it sits on your finger and
there's weights on it.
When you first put your thing and you
can take it off whenever you want,
when you first put your finger in there,
it doesn't hurt at all,
but the pressure,
some,
the pain detectors,
some of the pain and all always say is,
well tell us when this hurts.
So people are looking at it.
Oh,
it hurts.
Now we also say,
take your finger out when a reasonable
person would do so.
So you know,
they usually stayed there for about 30
seconds or so and then they say,
well,
you know,
that's enough.
It's completely harmless,
but the high self esteem is stay in
there longer than the most up to now you
might say,
well they're persistent.
Well they are.
They are persistent and sometimes that's
good and it's hard to tell when it's not
good,
but sometimes it's not good.
And I would say leaving your finger in a
laboratory pain device longer than
average.
It's probably not good
at
immediate behavioral.
If you're optimistic and you have these
far reaching goals that can be healthy.
If you apply those in small,
like my immediate behavioral level,
things like this should have been
behavioral like you're not supposed to
figure out cognitively.
Okay.
It's incremental.
Absolutely.
They will never.
I mean by definition they're optimistic.
Sense is why?
Because unless you have the ability to
adapt to the everyday information,
you can't learn and get.
Right.
That's the yes.
So that's,
that's a good explanation for the
phenomenon.
The experiment.
It's not a definitive experiment by
means,
but it's interesting because it even
argues against the short term utility of
a failure to process the information
that indicates that you're in here and
it is linked to self deception since we
use this self deception questionnaire.
So.
So you're,
you're putting the psychopathology of
neuroticism with psychopathy?
Yes,
I guess so.
I guess what I should say though,
having said that,
is that
this doesn't mean that I don't believe
that there are genetic predispositions
to different forms of psychopathology
and it also,
it also doesn't mean that I believe that
everyone plays on the same field,
so to speak.
So it may be an if you say you have an
extensive family history of
schizophrenia,
well that means that it's going to take
a lot less to push you over the edge,
then it would a normal person and the
fact that you've gone over the edge,
so to speak,
is not any indication necessarily that
your moral character was any less than
the next person's.
So the parameters of the game shift with
genetic and environmental context,
which is to say that I guess partly
different people have different
temptations and also different
weaknesses and,
but I do think that there's a moral
aspect to illness.
So
no,
that's pretty troublesome.
Okay.
Before we leave the,
uh,
tailor for Shelley Taylor hardcore,
real quick thing,
it's important to point out that what
she actually says,
and it's been pointed out,
I called the block.
Another critique is not the positive
illusions are correlated mental health,
but positive illusions are correlated
with the absence of depression and
anxiety,
which is a very different thing.
Well,
she takes the argument farther than that
because look,
she wrote a self help book for people
telling them how to use positive self
illusions to enhance the mental
function.
So there she's extrapolating beyond the
mere statement of absence of depression
and anxiety,
which is not a statement I have a
problem with because psychopaths for
example,
or low in depression and anxiety,
it's taking the argument the next step.
That's the problem.
Right?
So,
so I do think she goes beyond just,
well these,
these restricted forms of
psychopathology are less frequent among
people who are high in self deception.
That in itself is just an interesting
phenomenon.
It's the next step.
It's sort of disturbs me.
So is that so satisfying?
Yeah,
that's what I was saying.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Sorry,
I guess I misunderstood what you meant.
That's cool.
Is it magical to have hope in the face?
Like almost like hope against hope?
Well this is,
this argument gets more complicated.
They're like,
one of the things that she's found is
that people who say if you're diagnosed
with intractable cancer,
well she's found that people who
overestimate their chance of survival
live longer now this is,
this is tough.
I mean,
you know,
that's the piece of her evidence that's
really compelling,
but I would suggest,
and hopefully I can do more than suggest
at some point that that was because she
has optimism.
Her notion of self deception improperly
incorporates this sort of optimism that
we've been discussing.
It doesn't.
That card there that I couldn't just be
like,
I'm going to be one of the,
the psychopaths and play till the end
because I keep hoping that the next car
would be like the one that gives me a
quarter.
I hope I'm not pathological.
You don't
know how you behave in the task either.
So you know,
I wouldn't draw.
Don't draw inferences about your
behavior in hypothetical because you
don't know.
He might've stop.
Right?
I mean,
I don't do either.
Maybe you would play around with the Eq,
but it's also possible that some of the
people just didn't care about the damn
quarters.
Like the game,
thanks quarters to play the games at the
hurricane.
Awesome.
It's kind of a dog game.
We tell people you're supposed to win
the money.
It's like proper behavior during this
test is winning the money.
So the goal is set.
So mean,
you know,
like I said,
it's not,
it's not a definitive cakes.
So did you have,
did you have another college
I wanted to ask?
I'm talking about hope and,
and,
um,
anxiety and everything.
The words pride,
fear,
hatred and revenge.
What's the neuropsychological valence of
like rape,
like fears,
you know,
activation of the right.
But what about pride in this?
So,
I don't know about this,
but the,
the,
the negative emotions,
they tend to clump,
right?
If you look at the neuroticism scale of
the Neil,
all negative emotional states are in the
same subscale.
Essentially.
Egg Anger for example,
correlates very highly with fear.
So,
but we know the name
anger is activation of the left cortex.
And I was wondering if revenge might be
the same way.
I mean,
it seems like there's an approach,
there's an approach aspect rather than,
uh,
rather than avoiding.
Yeah,
no,
that's a good point.
If I don't know,
I don't know what we haven't.
We haven't progressed very far in the
study of sorts of higher order emotions.
I don't know what the neuropsychological
mean as you.
Anger is not necessarily proactive,
but active aggression certainly seems to
involve approach,
but so
a lot of it may be in response to the
become,
the farther you go in terms of overt
behavior,
the more complex it has to be from the
original impression.
Okay.
Well this is just to say that fear is
one of the fundamental responses that
happens that happens instantly in the
right frontal cortex,
but then as soon as you're getting into
hatred and revenge or getting into
plants,
secrets is naturally going to be
excavating systems in different systems
to though that's a really good.
That's an astute comment because when
you say aggression for example,
what you're saying is a word that
contains 40 different categories of
behavioral output because there's
defensive aggression,
there's instrumental aggression,
anger just been just for starters,
there's aggression that's socially
appropriate.
There's aggression that's socially
inappropriate.
There's aggression.
That's punishment elicited aggression.
That's fear elicited a aggression as a
response to challenge to group identity
and all those different things are under
the rubric of one word,
but as you point out involve activation
of systems.
It may be in complete opposition to one
another at times.
It seems to to be something that like if
it seems to me,
if there's two totally different things
in everyday life we call hope and one
would be sort of equivalent to the hero
and the other one would be equivalent to
like an over rigid identification with a
social structure because like if you say
you have hope in the future that that
look can be the kind of thing that keeps
you looking for other alternatives and
helps you find a way around.
Messaging sort of motivates you forward
into anomaly or whatever.
Like the hero to encounter the new
information.
Or you can have a kind of thing that we
don't distinguish.
We call it home too,
but it's the kind of thing where you say
it keeps you from finding a way around
things because you say this one though,
I felt like faith because hope I think
you can actually categorically defined
hope in a sense,
and I would say hope is what you
experienced as a consequence of the
positive valence of an anomalous
occurrence,
which is to say that you experienced the
effect of hope when you're faced with an
acute or satisfaction with an incentive
reward and that accompanies activation
left from the cortex is I think what
you're talking about is this and you're.
I think you're making a distinction
between blind faith,
which is,
oh,
everything's gonna.
Turn out wonderful.
You know what?
Even when the barbarians are at the
gate,
so to speak,
and the faith that says,
no matter what comes up,
which means I know that things will
transform.
I can deal with the transformations if
my attitude is proper and it's certainly
the case that those two things can be.
One is adolescent phase.
That's nice.
It's all my.
It isn't even faith in the sense its
reliance on the group,
like if I followed with a group of
maintained or protect me from those
things I can control.
The other one is,
you know,
I know the world is a dynamic place.
There's something in me that can respond
to it.
That's like an absolutely.
I think that's the antithesis of the of
the position that motivates the lock.
It's also the case.
See what other questions are trying to
answer is we know the group has it
protected nature.
That's also necessary,
but that can be pathologist,
so the question is given that the group
is necessary that it's maintenance is
necessary that people have to identify
with how is it that the pathological
aspect can be reduced and I would say to
the degree that you're able to move your
faith from blind reliance on the group
to have your own capacity to address
anomalous information and transform it
into unexplored territory.
You're you to the degree that you're
able to do that.
You can civil status when you're
dependent ties on the group because you
have this alternative standpoint.
That's great.
There's two ways.
There's two modes of protection from the
great unknown.
One is well,
dad will do everything.
That's one way of looking at the other
end as well.
No now saying can do everything,
but if I'm willing to meet whatever
happens when it happens,
I can heighten the probability of
success to to its highest possible level
that works out because first of all,
you're always practicing and that's.
That's psychological hygiene as far as
I'm concerned.
You know,
I think that's why so many religious
traditions concentrated on heightening
attention to day to day processes,
so there's little bits of anomalous
information are always cropping up in
your interpersonal interaction to your
professional work and everything that
you do and if you.
If you learn how to respond to those
normal occurrences that are relatively
small,
well they're happening.
First of all,
you keep your personality,
how you practice knowing how to do it,
so you increase your confidence in
yourself.
You decrease the amount of territory
around you,
this contaminated by the unknown,
and you increased the likelihood that
when something really catastrophic comes
along that you'll make the right
decision.
It's important,
you know,
because you see in places like Germany
for example,
and certainly not uniquely all sorts of
people who we might have hoped would
have been more resistant to the Nazi
ideology fell over like sheep when
paraded out the intellectual community
seemed to have no better record than the
community at large in Germany.
So,
which,
which to me indicates that despite their
accumulation of facts,
there was no concentration whatsoever on
the development of character.
We can necessarily weakens the
resistance of that.
Um,
so I'm trying to think about what,
how you can distinguish between the
optimist and the psychopath and your
experiments and what is used to be to
me,
uh,
in my experience and my experience that,
um,
or maybe at least from requirements that
the psychopath goes on ignoring threat.
But even while being punished,
I'm numb.
I'm trying to figure out if it's been
punished by the known or unknown unknown
things.
Because when he sticks his finger in the
thing,
that's something that's known that it's
going to hurt you.
You know,
they stick it in longer.
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
The optimist,
I think ignores the red but does not
keep going on when being punished
by,
by the known or the unknown.
I don't,
I don't.
If it breaks down,
it breaks down that straightforwardly.
Payne.
I'm the optimist is someone I think
who's willing to endure and voluntarily
meet threatening conditions in order to
attain their hand,
but who also modifies their behavior as
a consequence of encountered.
That's,
that's the critical time is the optimist
is who's healthy is,
has,
uh,
an ideal that may even be impossible.
In fact,
I think in some ways,
if you don't have an impossible,
then your ideal is wrong.
It should always supersede your grass.
That's the whole point of an ideal.
It's something that as you approach it,
it receives but transforms you along the
way.
So you might say,
well,
that's a pathological fantasy consensus.
It can never be brought into existence,
but there's a difference between
your conception of the future as an
ideal place and your and your belief
that despite all evidence to the present
is that ideal place at least in so far
as it's composed of you
art from all these other horrible people
that have been surrounded.
So like the distinction between
persistence and stubbornness or
hardheadedness or whatever.
I'm trying to understand the distinction
between a hope,
kind of hope necessarily report to risk
action and optimism.
Yeah.
Well,
again,
I would say that I would say that's
faith.
Actually Cornell West talks about leap
of hope.
Oh yes.
Okay.
Required to sustain political activism
face of.
Right.
In the face of evidence.
This face of evidence that all your
personal efforts are useless.
Yeah.
Right.
So that's healthy.
Depends.
Again,
it's very.
It's very dangerous to try to identify a
definition of something that can be
defined as healthy.
Okay.
That's all.
Let me see if I can address that.
Weren't particularly adaptive.
I mean our society is predicated on the
idea that despite all appearances,
something divine about the individual.
I think what Cornell West is referring
to is the necessity of acting on that
belief even though it,
even though number one,
it's incomprehensible,
and number two,
it seems to exist despite the evidence.
Now you say,
well,
what would separate that from a
delusion?
Well,
I think there is evidence to support the
notion that it's accurate because for
one thing,
those societies that make that
presupposition seemed to work much
better than those who don't.
And that strikes me as a form of
evidence plus,
I mean what we consider evidence that's
very difficult to to come to any
agreement about.
But it also strikes me that if you look
at traditional wisdom in these myths,
for example,
what's constantly pointed out is,
look,
you don't understand the function of the
individual.
There's more to it than meets the eye.
The more to it being at the individual
is the phenomenon that creates order out
of chaos.
So the incarnation of Martech,
so to speak,
plus the force that rejuvenates the
archaic social system when it needs to
be rejuvenated.
And now those two things,
account for the divinity of the
individual,
so to speak.
And I would say,
well,
even though it may not be evident to you
necessarily in your actions,
how that is playing out,
if you're doing it for the right
reasons,
then it will play itself out.
Neat.
You said,
all revolutions start invisibly,
which is his explicit recapitulation of
a hero myth because the hero's always
born under know trivial and threatened
conditions.
So Moses,
for examples,
he's gonna be he's threatened with death
by the Pharaoh and let go on a river and
in the Christian story,
Christ is born in the stable,
inherited,
threatens him with Gaf.
And that's just a sign that you know
terribly important things.
Many have the May have the outside
appearance,
even a failure,
but that's no indication necessarily
that their failure,
well then you say,
well,
how the hell do you separate that from
delusion?
Well,
that ties into that's a good way of
closing and that ties into this book.
He can't tell using objective evidence
if you're,
if what you're doing is going to be
successful,
partly because you have the wrong
timeframe.
So maybe the thing you're doing is
absolutely right.
No one knows for 300 years.
You're not going to know it because
you're not going to be here.
So how do you know?
Well,
the only thing I can say,
the only way I can think of that you
might know is by watching how your
actions,
by watching how your belief in actions
slip.
Say it again.
What is it that you want?
Let me just get this right.
The thing that tends to turn people
against life is the fact that life is
full of inexplicably tragedies.
I would say that if you can develop a
motive of an attitude towards the world
that is characterized by an increase in
the ability to bear,
it's tragic circumstances,
that that's evidence that your attitude
is correct.
Now,
the only person who's going to be able
to determine that is you,
because it's not going to be evident
necessarily the people around you and it
may not play out the way you would want
it to in the external world.
So then the question is how is it that
you can come to the state where you can
trust your own judgment about your
beliefs?
Given that people's beliefs get out of
hand all the time and they say,
well,
this belief is right,
well that that ties back into this.
If you fill up your head with
information that you know to buy your
own definitions of truth to be false,
then you can ensure that you're not
going to be able to trust your own
judgment.
Now,
the problem is there's going to be times
in your life where your judgment is the
only judgment that can even possibly be
valid and it it better be the case that
when you're in that circumstance that
your head is free enough of lives so
that you can be certain that the
decision you're making is right.
So I would say,
and this is the thing that's going to
underlie the last lecture in the course,
is there's two poles of this.
There's two.
Paul's that underlie your ability to
determine if you're on the right path is
way one is you're doing something that
you're interested in that's meaningful
enough so that you say,
even with all the tragedy of life,
the fact that I can do this makes it all
worthwhile.
And the second thing is,
you better make sure that you're not
diluted in what's making you interested
in and the only way you can be sure of
that is that you're not lying because
you might end up developing an interest
in the expert because that happens to
people or in slaughtering,
and then their interest guides them
somewhere.
It shouldn't have gone.
And I would say,
well,
that's because they pathologize
themselves by filling their brains,
so to speak,
filling their mind because the
information they know too,
they know is not vertical.
So there's two poles.
One is where something meaningful
manifests itself.
Follow it.
Now people want to do that anyway.
That's what makes your life interesting.
The other thing is whenever you have the
opportunity,
make sure that you tell yourself the
truth,
because if you don't,
your interest is going to become sick
and then a lead you somewhere.
You do not want to do it
anyways.
So our last classes next week,
hold everything up.
I have your assets.
Yes.
Would you say that most of the time if a
person continually the thing,
no,
it is.
That they might have behavior so much in
the days they don't like that.
It continually create like the weight,
let's say.
Would you say that that's probably
rationalization that most of it.